Narrator:
These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Tonight, Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made billionaire
investor Chris Sacca
joins the Tank.
Guard Llama believes that
your safety cannot wait.
I'm not even sure
there's a need for it.
So far,
we've done $95,000 in sales.
You are on the cusp
of the abyss.
Okay.
Is there another offer
on the table?
No, no, look ‐‐
I'm talking right now, so ‐‐
I'm ‐‐
Sorry. I'm ‐‐
The product's horrible.
Well...
You could tell him
to take a walk.
I hate this.
Ohh!
This is going
to zero for sure.
You said you pivoted
into this nightmare,
pivot the...
the beep out of it.
[ Wails ]
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is an innovation
in personal security.
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran:
Oh, it's a real llama.
Wow. Are they cool.
I've never seen one.
Have you?
O'Leary: That's crazy.
Wow.
[ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Nick Nevarez.
And I'm Joe Parisi.
Our company, Guard Llama, is
based out of Chicago, Illinois.
Whoo!
We are seeking $100,000
in exchange for 5%
of our company.
Guard Llama is
a state‐of‐the‐art
personal security platform
that provides discreet
and reliable security
in your everyday life.
Sharks, consider
the guard llama ‐‐
docile, unassuming,
non‐threatening...
[ Laughs ]
...at least
at first glance.
But when a predator approaches,
this all changes.
Llamas are known
for charging predators head on
with deadly force.
And now, Sharks, you, too, can
own a Guard Llama of your own.
I am not talking about
this magnificent animal...
[ Laughs ]
... but rather,
this wireless
Bluetooth remote.
Corcoran: Ooh.
Ooh!
What a disappointment.
We believe that it's
unrealistic to think
that in an emergency
you have time to dial 911,
have a conversation, which takes
over two minutes on average.
Parisi: Guard Llama believes
that your safety cannot wait,
so we've taken the liberty of
updating the process ourselves.
And here's how it works.
Visit our website
and purchase one Guard Llama
for every person you love,
including yourself.
Your remotes will arrive
in the mail
with instructions to set up
a physical profile.
This information is given
to the police
during your time of need
so they can identify you.
In the event
of an emergency,
simply double tap the button
on your GPS remote
to automatically activate
the Guard Llama system.
No more digging around
in your purse or pockets
searching for
a cellphone.
Your GPS location
and physical profile
are immediately sent
to a 24‐hour emergency
dispatch center,
and the police
now know exactly who are,
what you look like,
and where you're located
in under 30 seconds.
Sharks, invest in us
and help us guard millions
of lives with the Guard Llama.
Can we get samples?
Are you passing out anything?
Nevarez: Yes.
Of course.
Sacca: I got to be honest ‐‐
I'm a little let down.
I was thinking
this was gonna be, like,
sending llamas
to all these farms,
and you were gonna let
us finance that,
and I was super intrigued.
[ Laughs ]
Parisi:
I don't know if the margins
are as good on live llamas.
Are they good guard animals,
seriously?
Parisi: They're ph‐‐
They're phenomenal.
So, ranchers actually ‐‐
But why? They charge? They ‐‐
Yeah, they charge 'em head on.
They make noise?
Yeah, they make
noise as well.
Is it Bluetooth
to your phone?
Correct.
Do you have
to have your phone present
to actually activate it?
Yes. It works within
150 feet of your phone.
We believe that ‐‐
Cuban: So, it's Bluetooth
to your phone,
which indicates an app.
Correct. So, we have
an emergency dispatch center
in Springfield, Illinois,
that's staffed.
Cuban: Okay, so it goes to
an emergency dispatch center.
Parisi: Correct.
Cuban: How many customers
do you have?
How are you selling?
Where ‐‐ Give us the economics.
So, the products went live
last September.
Uh, we have 2,000 users.
We sell the product for $10
a month or $100 for the year.
And how are you acquiring
the users?
So, we have two different
customer acquisition strategies.
One is classic
online digital,
and then the other is
actually in‐person sales,
which have worked out
really well for us.
We have a partnership
with the National Association
of Realtors...
Mm‐hmm.
... and so, they know
that Realtors are at high risk
to be in trouble,
because there's
a lot of people...
When they're at a home,
and they're doing ‐‐
...going into vacant buildings
with people they don't know.
Mm‐hmm.
And so, they partnered with us
to provide that solution.
Greiner: So, let's say
that you have this with you.
All you have to do
is just press the button.
Correct. Twice.
Press it twice.
Then you will immediately
receive a phone call,
so it works just like
a home‐security system.
If you don't answer it,
it dispatches the police.
Oh, I see.
If you answer it,
you have an opportunity
to enter a disarm PIN.
If somebody's
robbing you ‐‐
Let's go through this scenario.
Yep.
I press the button,
the phone rings,
the potential thief is...
Says "Answer your phone."
They answer the phone 'cause
they're worried who's calling...
Yep.
... and they say, "Yeah, hi.
Is this,
uh, Dolly Llama?"
Right. So they say,
"Please enter
your disarm PIN."
So now the thief goes...
Okay.
..."Oh, you activated a system.
Disarm it."
So, you go, "Okay."
You can enter any PIN except
for your actual disarm PIN,
and it will say, "Thank you
for entering your disarm PIN.
Have a great day."
It hangs up. The thief thinks
that it's been disarmed.
The police come anyways.
The police come anyway,
and now we can communicate
to the police that they
actually entered a distress PIN.
I get it.
So, not only did they indicate
they need help,
but they've gone out of their
way to confirm an incorrect PIN.
What about colleges?
I mean, I'm trying to think of
where is it...
Colleges are great.
... easy for you
to do the sales?
Parents would pay, right?
Parisi: Yeah.
O'Leary: There's
a competing system
where you're walking around ‐‐
Barbara wears this all the time
in her house ‐‐
It's a blue box.
"I've fallen down,
and I can't get up!"
Right.
And they have
the inherent problem of brand.
No college student is carrying
a Life Alert around.
What I can tell you guys
is that it sells.
Cuban: I get that
this is an easy sell.
I like everything about your
company except for the product.
♪♪
The product's horrible.
Cuban: I get that
this is an easy sell.
I like everything about your
company except for the product.
♪♪
The product's horrible...
and I'll tell you why ‐‐ you
only have 2,000 users, right?
If you have 200,000 users
or 2 million users,
someone, unfortunately, is going
to have serious consequences,
and the minute one of those
people have serious consequences
because, "A",
they didn't have it,
or, "B", "I turned off
my GPS because the
alerts were annoying",
or whatever,
life happens, right?
And because of all
those extra connections
that need to take place
for this to work,
too many things
can go wrong.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I think it's a great idea
and a great product.
But, for me, if it didn't work
in once instance
and something happened,
it can be a liability nightmare.
So while I love the product,
I'm out.
Okay.
[ Soft plop ]
The llama just took a dump.
Oh, and even more.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my.
This is amazing!
Okay, so...
How do you think
your pitch is going?
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I get it.
T‐The trouble with this deal
is 5% of a s‐‐ basically
a start‐up here ‐‐
making this thing a $2 million
valuation makes no sense to me,
but I‐I'll make you an
offer, but I'm gonna
structure it differently,
because I'm so low
on the cap table,
I'm just ‐‐
5% is a nothing burger.
I don't even think about it.
[ Wails ]
You're right.
[ Laughs ]
So, here's the way
I'd structure this.
This goes back
to a classic royalty deal
that I've made legendary
on "Shark Tank,"
but it works for you.
I give you the $100,000.
Every time you sell
a subscription,
you give me $5 back
until I've recouped $120,000.
Then the royalty goes away.
So, I made 20% on my money.
And for the trouble that
I'm putting myself into,
I take the 5% equity,
because I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I'm part of your company now,
and I'm worth it ‐‐ big time.
[ Snorts ]
[ Laughs ]
Parisi: Thank you.
O'Leary: That's an offer.
Yeah. That's fantastic.
Thank you so much.
All right.
I appreciate it.
Is that an acceptance?
Oh, I'm ‐‐
Here's the thing ‐‐ I understand
how compelling the problem is
that you're going after.
That said, this has
so many warts for me.
The direct‐sales model is
a nightmare and hard to scale.
I realize it's been successful
to you up to date,
but for
the first 2,000 users,
you might be able
to pull that off.
I think your brand is soft,
too,
and I think you've built nothing
proprietary other than a button,
so I'm out.
Parisi: Well, there was
a woman last week
who was
in the trunk of a car,
and they killed her
before they could find her.
She was on the phone
with the sheriff
telling them,
"I'm in the trunk of a car."
They could not find her.
She's dead.
But how does your product
solve the problem?
Because we can get ‐‐ the same
way an Uber can find you ‐‐
Because of the locator.
That makes sense.
We use the GPS chip.
My younger brother
was on a motorcycle
a year and a half ago,
a truck hit him,
and we couldn't find him
for two days.
Wow.
He was in a coma.
Luckily, he survived, uh,
but I personally was shocked
that we couldn't have
a local cop
simply tap into his GPS,
but the privacy federal laws
forbade that.
Yeah.
And so I think there's
a real need for your product.
I'd like to make you
an offer.
I'll give you $100,000 loan
at no‐interest rate for 20%,
and I want $2 per sale
until I recoup money,
and then it goes away.
Because your sweet spot on this
is it's a panic button.
If you approach the Realtors,
I'm convinced that's the easiest
low‐hanging fruit you'd grab.
Okay?
Parisi: I agree.
And, of course,
I know that space,
because I'm the sweetheart
of all the Realtors,
and so if I was fronting for
you, you would sell like crazy.
You have to pay 20% equity ‐‐
that's a lot.
That's a lot.
But, you know, I‐‐
I'm gonna stick
with my offer.
You can choose.
All right. Um...
Barbara,
will you do 15%?
Um, no, but I'll do
18%.
[ Wails ]
[ Laughs ]
All right. Let's do it.
Done? Got it.
Cuban: Congrats, Barbara.
Greiner: Congrats.
All righty, baby.
Parisi: I am a good salesman
after all.
Nevarez: Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Have a good one, guys.
Thank you.
Parisi: Now that we've stuck
a deal with Barbara,
we are going to take
the real‐estate market
and move on to helping provide
safety and security
to the rest of America.
It's unbelievable.
I mean, we were in there,
and I got to be telling you ‐‐
when he starting pooping,
I was like,
"What the heck is going on?!"
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: In season five,
Al "Bubba" Baker
made a deal with Daymond John
for his patented
boneless baby back ribs.
I think I'm gonna
take Daymond's deal.
Ah!
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
John: Today I'm in St. Louis
with Al "Bubba" Baker
and his daughter Britney to meet
with Carl's Jr. and Hardee's.
We have been working together
to develop a special burger
with Bubba's ribs.
How are you doing?
Thanks for having us.
Today, we're here to find out
how it turned out
and, hopefully, get it
on the menu.
Baker: Carl's Jr. and Hardee's
came up to my booth
at a food show, because
it's a patented boneless rib.
We're the only people in
the United States to do it.
We think it's gonna be
a great success.
We are prepared to put
the Baby Back Rib Burger
in our 3,000 locations.
Wow.
Wow!
We are going to have to order
about a million pounds,
so, Al ‐‐
A million pounds?!
So, we're going to make
a multimillion‐dollar offer.
[ Laughs ]
Any time you have a project
that's 30‐something years
in the making,
and when you finally see
it coming to fruition,
the emotions ‐‐
it was overwhelming.
Thanks a lot, Al.
Thanks, Al.
Thank you!
Before "Shark Tank,"
our sales were $154,000.
It's been three years,
and sales are now
at $16 million,
and I just can't believe it.
And here they are.
John: The future
couldn't be brighter for Al.
I still believe that
this will potentially be
my biggest deal ever.
This is amazing.
I've been very lucky
in my life ‐‐
first to go to college,
to play in the
National Football League,
and then to take my business
to "Shark Tank,"
it's proof that if you live
your life with integrity,
and if you work hard,
good things happen to you.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a photo‐printing service
with an unique business model.
Hi, I'm Sam.
And I'm Savannah.
We're here to talk to you about
Flag and are seeking $375,000
in return for a 5% stake
in our company.
The number of photos taken
each year has tripled since 2010
and is projected to grow
to 1.3 trillion by 2017.
And as you probably know,
75% of photographs taken today
are taken on phones.
Because my phone is always
on me and my kids are so cute
and my life is so interesting,
I take photos every day.
But even the best ones may never
make it off my phone, laptop,
and I could break them
or lose them.
That's why
we created Flag,
the world's first truly free
photo‐printing app.
No printing charge.
No shipping charge.
No subscription.
No credit card required.
So, how do we do it?
We're using the blank space
on the back of photographs
that's been wasted
for over 100 years
to deliver targeted ads.
The idea is simple ‐‐ you get
beautiful, free photo prints,
advertisers get to connect
themselves with your memories
and deliver ads
that will be kept for decades.
So, Sharks, we urge you
to capture the opportunity
and help us
to develop Flag...
And print money...
Both: ...together.
[ Laughs ]
Can we see some samples?
Definitely.
O'Leary: Thank you.
You're welcome.
There are some
very large companies...
Yes.
...that take people's
photographs,
print them,
and ship them to you.
Yes.
We sold Grovebook to ‐‐
What? ‐‐ Shutterfly.
If this model were to work,
why wouldn't they simply offer
the same deal
to their millions
of customers?
We've thought about that,
obviously.
I'm glad!
[ Laughs ]
So, what's the answer
to that question?
Well, there are
a couple of things
that a lot of people don't
realize about photo printing.
To make double‐sided prints
actually requires
a different
technological stack
than companies like Shutterfly
have in place.
Now, they could do it if
they invested a lot of money.
The reason that we can do all of
these fancy shapes and finishes,
and we can do completely
variable orders,
is 'cause we're
laser‐cutting our prints.
They don't do that.
Here's a little version
of the app.
This is how you
choose custom frames.
This is something people
haven't been able to do before.
I choose the picture
of my daughter,
I tap on the frame
that I want to use.
It's really simple.
How are you
getting people to pay
for the advertising
on the back?
And how many do you have?
We have sold $150,000
in advertising in 3 months.
To various clients.
So, what kind of companies
have you actually sold to?
Who are they?
So ‐‐
Yeah, go
with the number‐one.
It's Visa.
And Visa loves
what we're doing.
I've never heard of them.
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: Visa is one
of your customers?
Yes, they realize that
we have the ability
to brand really well, because
we're turning ads into gifts.
How much money have
you guys raised to date?
We've raised
$1.6 million.
Ohh!
Greiner: Wow!
At what valuation?
Well, we didn't raise it
all in one chunk.
The last money
that we closed ‐‐
a year ago, we did at
a $5 million valuation.
Corcoran:
Did you mention how many photos
you've sent out to date
with an advertisement
on the back?
Sure, so ‐‐
So we've been in market
three months, and each month
we've sent out 80,000
to 100,000 prints per month.
Wow.
We're outsourcing
all of our production right now.
When we insource, our cost
per pack will come down.
We'd we looking
at 20‐cent ad costs.
Greiner:
What does it cost per card,
and what is the ad revenue
you get per card?
We're selling ads
for a buck an ad.
Really?
Yeah.
That better be really targeted
advertising for your customer.
Well, it is,
and it's print.
It's ‐‐ These aren't clicks.
These are things that live
in people's houses.
Something that people
will never throw away.
You've got to compare
these things to catalogs.
[ Chuckles ] In the back of
a frame through, right?
We ship 20 prints free
each month.
People aren't gonna frame
20 photos a month.
Sure.
And our prints
are such high quality,
it's the kind of thing
you pass on to friends,
put up in your cubicle at work,
display on your coffee table.
Are your ads
working for them?
Our ads haven't started
running for them yet.
We've sold them.
We've done the deal.
We've been paid.
Sacca: But is the
laser‐printing technology
or the double‐printing
technology exclusive to you?
No.
Cuban: So, if I ‐‐ I ‐‐
If we wanted to go out
and buy one of each
of those printers,
we could do it ourselves?
Yes, theoretically
you could.
O'Leary: There's nothing
proprietary about this.
And, you know,
you're nice people,
but I'm worried a big foot
is gonna come down
and just squash you
like the cockroaches you are.
The reason why we're here
is we absolutely need
to insource production.
Right now we're spending
a lot of money
by printing in one facility,
cutting at another,
laminating at another.
Cuban: But something
doesn't make sense.
You've raised $1.6 million.
Yes.
You're asking for ‐‐
$375,000.
Right, $375,000 is gonna get you
what you need
to bring it in house.
Why don't you use the $375,000
out of the $1.6 million?
Actually, we are raising
right now $3 million.
Oh, and you didn't think
you should tell us that?
I'm ‐‐ Sorry.
I'm ‐‐ I apologize.
Corcoran:
You raised $1.6 million.
Yes.
You're looking at us
to raise additional money.
I don't like the way
those numbers sound
and going through a heck
of a lot of cash, so I'm out.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
Can I ‐‐ Can I say one thing
about our ad‐sales model?
And besides which ‐‐ for some
reason, I don't trust you.
O'Leary: Ohh!
I'm ‐‐ That's a ‐‐
I'm ‐‐ I'm really sor‐‐
That's natural for Barbara.
It could be
that English accent.
[ Laughing ]
I'm sorry to ‐‐
O'Leary:
What I want to know ‐‐
and everybody else
is in the same boat here ‐‐
every Shark's got the same
question ‐‐ does it work?
And we don't know.
Can I ‐‐
The thing is is that we've been
in market three months,
and big brands
are compelled by the idea
that this is something
that people are...
They want to test it.
We don't know
if Visa's coming back.
We have to find out if
the advertisers get a return.
Yeah.
And you should be motivated...
[ Spanish accent ]
Itchy, wowwa, caramba ‐‐
[normal voice] you want
to solve this problem.
Cuban:
That's why they're here.
Cowley: Absolutely.
We have ‐‐ We have ‐‐
But the answer isn't just to
take more dough from investors.
You should be saying to them,
"Look, Visa's coming back.
It worked, and now
we need money."
I feel like
I have to come over
and spank you with a ruler...
Greiner: I know.
...for not staying focused on
the thing that matters,
because you are on the cusp
of the abyss, the darkness...
W‐‐
... the evil of going to
friggin' zero with a bullet.
So, what are you gonna do,
Kevin?
Well, I'm out.
Can I ‐‐ Can I ‐‐
Okay.
I want to share with you
a story.
Several years ago, we had a new
product that was launching.
We decided,
smartest thing to do ‐‐
we will give them away
for free,
and they'll come back
and buy it again.
I'll just post it
on my social.
So, we launched it at midnight,
and, I'm not joking you,
by 12:30, 5,000 were gone.
Before we know it,
it's 3:00 a. m.,
and it's something
like 35,000 are gone.
That taught me
a hard‐and‐fast lesson.
When you give away
anything for free,
there are going
to be millions of takers.
But then on the flip side,
the problem is
is you need advertisers
to help you to pay
for all this free product.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Cuban: You've got
so many moving pieces.
You've got to raise
a lot of money
so that you can insource
so your costs are reasonable.
Then you've got
to find enough users,
which is
gonna cost you money.
If you're able
to solve those problems,
then you're just
in the advertising business
and having to prove
that your ads work better
than everybody else.
You add all those up,
and I see that as an
insurmountable set of problems,
so for those reasons,
I'm out.
I ‐‐ I ‐‐ Well,
I want to make sure
there's one thing
that's clear ‐‐
This is definitely
a freemium model.
We don't anticipate
that all of our revenue
is gonna coming from
advertising.
Sacca: Wait. You guys,
we're in the 11th hour,
and you're just now gonna pivot
and tell us you're freemium?
It's not ‐‐ It's not ‐‐
It's not a pivot,
and I'm ‐‐
I really ‐‐ I ‐‐
Somebody call a doctor, 'cause
this pitch needs CPR right now.
I mean, you've got
to be kidding me.
You're bringing it up now?
You're one competitor
having a laser printer away
from not being able to charge
anything for that. Come on.
Well ‐‐
When you guys walked in,
I thought I smelled like a
little bit of smoke in the air,
then I realize
it's from the bonfire of cash
you guys are burning back
at your headquarters.
I don't usually invest
in businesses
that are doing
old‐school ads
with a really weak
business model
in crowded markets
with five‐alarm cash burn.
Can I ‐‐
And this time
is no different.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Sorry, guys. Good luck.
Corcoran: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Greiner: Good luck, guys.
♪♪
Agboola:
We didn't get a fair hearing,
and they lost an opportunity
to invest in
a disruptive business.
So, it's a little sad
all around.
I kind of
feel sad for them.
Why do you feel sad?
I don't feel bad at all.
It was horrible.
I feel s‐‐
It was horrible!
Well, I ‐‐ I ‐‐
It was h‐‐
more than horrible.
A moment of silence
for the money that's died.
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Next up is a company
hoping to solve a pain point
for brick‐and‐mortar businesses
and consumers.
It's the Drew Carey
triplets.
[ Laughter ]
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Ian.
I'm Alex.
And I'm Tov.
We are the founders of Validated
from Portland, Oregon.
We are here today seeking
a $250,000 investment
in exchange for 8%
in our company.
Whether it's $16 parking or a
sudden surge in your ride share,
getting around is expensive, and
these costs can keep you away
from the shops and restaurants
that you love.
What if I told you your favorite
shops, bars, and restaurants
would cover your ride?
Introducing Validated, the app
that lets you earn free parking
and free rides
when you shop and dine.
Think of it like free shipping
for yourself.
We'll discover the businesses
around you
that will help cover
your transportation costs
in exchange for being
their customer.
Just tap a business to see
what's required to qualify
and how much
they'll validate.
Once you've spent
the required amount,
simply slide and scan
to unlock validation credits.
Stack credits from multiple
shops and restaurants,
and then redeem them
to your preferred mode
of transportation.
It's a win‐win proposition that
makes getting around less a drag
and boosts businesses'
bottom line.
So, Sharks, which of you
is ready to get Validated?
It's interesting
because it gets people
back into
brick‐and‐mortar easier.
Yeah, and th‐‐ and
that's exactly what we're ‐‐
what we're seeing, Lori,
is that businesses
are doing anything
that they can
to get foot traffic
back in the stores per customer.
W‐W‐Wait. Bar‐‐
Let me ask you
a simple question,
because I ‐‐
I really don't get it.
Arnerson: Yeah?
When I shop and I get
a dress for $200,
they will give me,
basically, free parking?
They will give you
credits based on that spend.
But would it be enough
for me to park my car
and shop for three hours?
Totally depends
on the merchant.
So, we let the merchants
set their own offers
and their own spending
thresholds.
But even that vagueness, I would
think, from the consumer view,
uh, would be confusing
and not that motivational.
The exciting thing about it is
that you can stack up as you go.
So, let's say you're gonna go
out on ‐‐ on the town,
you're gonna buy
a pair of shoes,
you're gonna go have lunch,
you're gonna hit a movie.
You can validate as you go, and
as you stack those credits up
you can easily pay
for your whole trip.
Sacca:
Give us some numbers.
Give us some sense of success
or failure so far.
So, right now we have
50 merchants
in our launch cities
of Seattle and Portland.
Right now, we're averaging
about 25 validations
per merchant
across those 50.
And so, the numbers are low.
We're early.
How early? How long has
this been in business?
So, we started
this last July.
We kind of pivoted
from something else
into this business.
Uh, by last fall, we had
a minimum viable product,
and we've been rolling
this thing out.
Tech question for you guys ‐‐
what were you scanning?
We were scanning a QR code
that's essentially
a benign token
that is currently ‐‐
Right, but where is that?
What ‐‐ It looked somebody
was holding something?
Yeah, exactly.
So, essentially
you would walk up to the
merchant at the cash out
and would ask,
"Can I get validated?"
The merchant has it behind
the counter and shows it.
Okay, so the merchant
has their code...
Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
... and you just scan it.
So, what would you estimate
the value of a point to be?
So, what we ‐‐
Sacca: No, to be clear ‐‐
So it's one‐to‐one
per dollars.
Wait. Wait.
Okay, can we just get rid of ‐‐
You're not parking your car.
It's equal to a dollar?
This is ‐‐ This is to get you
a ride to and from, right?
So it's really like one credit
is one dollar.
One credit, one dollar?
Uh, you can ‐‐ you can push
validation credits for parking.
So, we're gonna be partnering
with PayByPhone,
which has 12 million users.
They're a parking‐payment
processing app.
It doesn't need
to be that complicated.
Look, Uber works 'cause
it's push a button, get a ride.
Your whole model should be "Buy
some stuff, get a ride," period.
Like, not "Park your car,"
and not, like,
"Hey, you can buy
some of the stuff here,
and some of the stuff there,
and split your car
parked on this level and
that level and buy more time."
The minute you say, "Use your
transportation mode of choice,"
and I start seeing you integrate
public‐transportation systems
and all that stuff,
you've just made your comp‐‐
your product
so unnecessarily complex.
Yeah, but they've got
bigger problems, right,
because you have to be the bank
for the points.
We are the bank, yes.
And you have to convince people
that the currency is valuable,
so you're also
the Federal Reserve.
That's a nightmare.
Right?
Chris suggests Uber,
but that's a limited option.
[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Not everybody uses Uber.
No one's ever called 85%
of the market
a "limited option."
Well, no, no, but it's still
not ‐‐ not everybody's
gonna use it.
You just drove to the mall.
Chances are you didn't drive
to the mall in an Uber.
Well, the chances
are extremely high
you just went to the mall
in an Uber, actually.
Right, that's why parking lots
are empty.
Yes, Uber, Lyft ‐‐ they are kind
of the zeitgeist right now.
Everybody wants to use it.
But in
the transportation pie,
if you look at it,
it's actually below 5%.
Be honest ‐‐ when you start
slicing it to the people
who have an iPhone,
who download apps,
who are in the target market
for your advertisers,
it's a huge, huge piece
of the pie.
Definitely, definitely.
No doubt. Yes.
So we're not including,
you know, Florida retirees
who go to the 4:00...
That's not the issue.
It doesn't even matter, right?
It doesn't matter.
... early‐bird dinner.
The point is
you're the bank.
Let's be honest here.
You're a consumer bank
and you're the Federal Reserve,
which complicates things
to an extreme.
You have so many
integration points
with all the different
participants.
It's burdensome, and there's
gonna be ongoing bugs forever.
That makes it more expensive.
The ‐‐ The ‐‐
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
You know, this sounds
so complicated.
Maybe I'm missing
the point here.
It's ‐‐ It's n‐‐
I'm not even sure
there's a need for it.
I'm definitely out.
Okay. So, let me just address
Barbara's point.
So, the reason that
there's a need for it
is because retailers are seeing
everyone move to online, right?
And so when you buy a product
in e‐commerce,
what happens is 33%
of the time that product
is shipped back, and there's
this endless volley, right?
And so, what the
brick‐and‐mortar retailer
want to do is they want
to get people in the store.
I hate this.
This is going
to zero for sure.
You said you pivoted
into this nightmare.
Pivot the...
the beep out of it.
This is a dog.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You know,
I see some merit.
I could see restaurants
really loving it.
I'm not sure, though,
how many people
are gonna be using the app,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Thank you.
I initially saw the tag line
in the first couple of screens,
and I'm like,
"That is smart".
Mm‐hmm.
"These guys are
driving traffic
on a deal‐discovery basis."
And then with each additional
slide, you lost me.
It's complicated.
There's choices.
The user experience sucks.
"We're gonna try and accommodate
your car and your parking
in this level
and that level,"
and then you show me
the QR code.
QR codes are the herpes
of mobile technology.
It should be as simple as
"Buy some stuff, get a ride,"
period.
Look, I don't believe
you're gonna make it.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Good luck, guys.
Please,
light the QR codes on fire.
Yeah, you don't want
to be a bank.
You want to be
a connection.
Thank you.
Tov: The way that we understand
our business,
the way that we understand
our customers
is far beyond, uh,
what they understand...
Mm‐hmm.
...and I think it's been so long
that they worried
about paying
for transportation,
they don't understand,
like, what a pain point it is
for the rest of us.
♪♪
I'm Brian.
And I'm Kyle.
And our business is
Guardian Bikes.
I first came up
with the idea
seven years ago
when I was in college.
My grandfather got in a really
serious bike accident
and broke several vertebrae
in his neck.
He fully recovered
after a couple years,
but it was a traumatic
experience for me and my family.
That work?
Nice.
There's a lot of
other technologies out there
where when you get
in an accident,
it helps to not make them
so severe,
but what's great
about our technology is
it prevents accidents from ever
happening in the first place.
Just like seat belts
and windshield wipers
become safety standards
in the car industry,
we want to make our technology
the safety standard in bikes.
Not bad.
Here we go.
Our families have invested
over $100,000 in our business.
Even my grandpa invested
in our business,
so there's a lot of pressure
to succeed.
What happened
to my grandfather,
I don't want to see happen
to anybody else,
and that's why we're trying
to bring this technology
to as many people
as we can.
We know we can make
millions of dollars
and also prevent
hundreds of thousands of people
from going to the emergency room
each year.
[ Tires scraping ]
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Brian Riley.
And I'm Kyle Jansen.
We're from
Irvine, California,
and our company is
Guardian Bikes.
We're seeking
a $500,000 investment
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks, riding a bike is
an essential joy of childhood.
It's almost
a rite of passage
when you can finally take off
on your own.
However, those
early experiences don't come
without the risks
of an occasional spill.
Parents are always
looking for ways
to keep their kids safer.
We're here to help.
Guardian has created the world's
safest children's bikes.
The secret sauce
to Guardian Bikes
is our patented
SureStop technology.
Similar to antilock brakes
in cars,
SureStop solves the problem
of incorrect braking.
On a traditional bike,
if a child brakes too hard
or pulls the wrong brake lever
at the wrong time,
the front wheel can
stop too soon,
causing the bike
to flip over.
Mm‐hmm.
Not with Guardian Bikes.
SureStop uses just
one lever
and always actives
the rear brake first,
and then intelligently
adds in the front brake,
eliminating the chance of ever
going over the handlebars.
With both front and rear brakes
always engaging,
kids can stop faster
and with more control.
But we didn't want
to stop at just safety.
None of this matters
unless kids love their bike.
So we designed our bikes
to appeal to kids
with striking designs that
make them not only the safest,
but the coolest kids bikes
on the block.
So, Sharks,
are you ready
to help us bring Guardian Bikes
to every family in America?
Sacca:
So, let me ask you guys,
which one of you guys
has scars to prove
that you had wipeouts like that
as a kid, 'cause I g‐‐
[ Laughs ]
Literally, I have
this huge gash in my chin
from that exact wipeout.
We both have the scars,
and the whole inspiration for ‐‐
for the company is
my grandfather
had that exact accident,
and he was really unfortunate
and landed on his head and broke
several vertebrae in his neck.
Oh, wow.
And it was a ‐‐
It was a terrifying thing for ‐‐
for me and my whole family
to have a family member
go through that.
My question right
out of the gate for you guys
is why in the world
would you go forward
and build a bike company
when you've got a technology
that every bike company
would want?
I was thinking
the same thing.
And ‐‐ And you would go there
and license it to them
and not have
all of the headache
of marketing
a new bike company.
The way
that we entered the market
is actually
by being a component supplier
and, essentially,
licensing the technology.
So we're actually
in the market right now.
SureStop,
our brake technology,
is on 40,000 bikes out
in the market.
Now you're talking!
Oh, really?
Now that's
a lot more interesting.
That's more interesting.
Yes, yes, so...
By the way,
can I try it?
Yeah, that's ‐‐
Absolutely.
Give him the one that
won't stop.
[ Laughs ]
I do want to look at how
it's integrated.
Yeah.
Y‐You guys can come up
and look at this close up, too.
The easiest way is
to look at it right up here.
So, lookit ‐‐
These are the most common
types of brakes
in the world.
Sacca: Yeah.
This pad drops in,
when it hits the rim,
the force of the wheel
just slides it.
It all mechanically
pulls on ‐‐
Sacca: So, the only thing
that's actually different
about this
is from here forward,
just on the regular caliper.
That part, right there,
is genius, actually.
Yep.
Or even ‐‐
So, hold on.
Let's watch this character.
[ Laughter ]
Corcoran: Character.
Greiner: So, like antilock
brakes in your car,
it's antilock braking system
for you bike.
Exactly.
Does it do, like,
the du‐du‐du?
No, they d‐‐
You know?
You don't feel that?
No, this is
much more smooth.
It just brakes it?
And it took us a while
to develop a rubber compound
that would give you
enough braking power...
I'd watch out.
... but not enough
where it feels jumpy.
Yeah, let's get him out
of the way, there.
O'Leary: You know what?
I'm having a childhood moment.
I'll see you guys later.
[ Laughter ]
Good, he's gone.
I'll do a deal just
for that reason.
Sacca: It's a genius solution.
I've seen this problem.
This solves it immediately.
It's great.
Well ‐‐
So, why haven't all
the bike companies adopted it
unless it's a huge
cost increment?
Yeah, well, we ‐‐
we offer it right now
for about a $4 cost increase
to a bike.
Corcoran: That's all?
That's fantastic.
The big problem
that we're seeing is,
some of the major manufacturers
tell us,
"If I put this
on some of my bikes,
it makes all my other bikes
look dangerous."
And so we're getting a lot
of resistance. We've been ‐‐
That's dumb.
It's dumb.
They should put it
on every bike.
We totally agree.
So, but ‐‐
Tell us your sales
and break it out for us.
Yeah, yeah.
With SureStop,
we sell the pad for about $5,
so we've got out 40,000 bikes.
That's about $200,000
in sales,
and it's taken us
about three years to do that.
So we're launching
the Guardian Bikes.
We've launched those
about seven months ago.
Kyle can go
into the sales with those.
So far,
we've done $95,000 in sales.
We project that we'll
get to about $350,000
in our first year.
We look at Guardian
as giving us revenue.
It's scaling revenue
a lot faster
than the licensing model
was,
but it's a Trojan horse, because
we're educating the market
on why this is safer
with our own bikes.
We're the only ones ‐‐
But that's expensive, expensive,
expensive, expensive,
both from a marketing
and a capital investment
for your inventory.
Well, actually, it's returning
us a lot of revenue,
and that way,
we can make a lot more money,
you know, per sale
than the licensing side,
which is oftentimes
waiting like
a year‐and‐a‐half
sales cycles.
We need to get to the point
where we're doing, you know,
millions of bikes,
and we can get there.
We've got, uh, Pacific Cycle,
which is, you know,
the single biggest manufacturer
of bikes by volume
in the United States.
They have finally gone forward,
and they're pitching
a SureStop‐equipped model
into Walmart.
Yeah, that doesn't make sense,
like, to me.
Yeah.
If it's $4 to put this
on your bike,
and you keep your kids safer,
why would you not take this
and put it
on every single bike you have?
They've tried.
You know what?
It ‐‐ It just ‐‐
It does not make sense to me.
And you have a patent.
Yes, and, Lori, the reason ‐‐
And you could go
to one of the majors, and ‐‐
The reason why we got
into making our own bikes
was one of them told me,
he said,
"Well, if I put this on
some bikes and I don't
put them on others,
I might get sued that I didn't
have it on another bike."
Getting the distribution
into the major points of sale
is extremely challenging.
It requires a tremendous amount
of capital.
We've gone from zero
to selling in 65 bike shops
in about 7 months.
We're adding ‐‐
It's nothing.
I‐I know,
but we're adding ‐‐
It's nothing.
But it's getting the company
to a point
where we're making money.
Corcoran: You want to know
what you're missing?
You're missing a salesman.
Well...
If a great salesman
had had that opportunity
to FaceTime
with the bike manufacturers,
I got to believe you'd be
in a different position.
I'm sorry, but I'm out.
All right,
thanks, Barbara.
Thanks.
Tell us what
a Guardian Bike costs
versus any other bike.
The 24‐inch bike get
its landed cost of $146,
and we sell it wholesale
for $240.
The smaller size here ‐‐
we landed for $132,
and we sell it for $228.
That's a more expensive bike
than I could buy
for a kid at Walmart.
Yeah.
But we've started with
the most premium bike first,
and that's
what these ones are.
We can introduce bikes
at different price points
whenever we want.
We want to be known
as making
the safest children's bike,
the best children's bike ‐‐
What's been the biggest outlet
you've received PR in so far?
Well, the way that we've gotten
most of our sales
online, for example, is,
there's a review site
called Two Wheeling Tots,
and they said
these bikes are truly safer
than what's out there,
and that's lead to, really,
100% of our online sales.
But you're doing it
as a Trojan horse
to get the big guys to play
with you anyways.
L‐Let me be very clear
on your mistake ‐‐
Your marketing sucks.
Your PR strategy sucks.
You didn't come in here
telling us
how you were gonna
make parents aware
that they need to be
buying these bikes
for safety reasons, right?
You haven't told us how
you're gonna get there at all.
You haven't told us
about a social‐media strategy.
about giving it to influencers.
This is really what your deal
boils down to ‐‐
Could I forbid you
from making Guardian Bikes?
I could keep you focused
on what has to get done.
In the meantime, you're wasting
your time listening
to Cuban's crap
about building bikes
when he knows there's not
a chance in hell
you'll make money
doing that long term.
They already are.
They're making nothing!
2,000 bikes is nothing.
Let's say if I gave you
500K for 20%,
but you're forbidden
from building bikes.
Yes or no?
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Brian and Kyle have an offer
on the table from Kevin
for their safer‐brake
technology company,
Guardian Bikes.
But it comes
with a big contingency.
Let's say if I gave you
500K for 20%,
but you're forbidden
from building bikes.
Yes or no?
Corcoran:
Gosh. [ Laughs ]
You could tell him
to take a walk.
I don't want you spending
any of your time
competing in the
bicycle manufacturing business.
All of your time
should be spent
focusing on getting
the OEM license.
You need adult supervision.
You can't keep doing this.
You can't spend your time
building bikes
and selling them
one at a time.
Imagine the power of an adult
making you focus
on what it's gonna take
to make you rich.
[ Laughs ]
Why don't you take ‐‐
I just want to focus these guys
on concrete answers.
Yeah.
So what I can't get a straight
answer from you guys on is,
is this really
the smartest decision?
You're gonna go through
all the headache
of being in a bike‐manufacturing
company
and everything you're gonna need
to do in terms of design
and promotion and marketing
and all that stuff.
Is it because you're able
to capture more share
than the $4 you're gonna make
in a royalty per unit?
That's what
I'm struggling with.
To give you an example,
REI sells SureStop‐equipped
bikes already
in every one of their REI stores
on their house brand.
But that's only
about 4,000 bikes a year,
so you make four bucks off
4,000 bikes a year.
It doesn't create
enough revenue.
So we needed
a Trojan horse,
we needed our own bike brand,
and this is what we're doing.
Proof of concept business.
Exactly, exactly.
Yep.
You're at a fork in a road.
One road,
you can see down the road.
The sun is shining, butterflies
are flying in the breeze,
beautiful flowers
are blooming.
The other road,
straight into hell
in perpetuity.
Guardian is
the road to hell.
The other one is you simply wait
out the manufacturers,
get as much PR around ‐‐
No, you've got it backwards.
They wait out them.
Yeah, it's ‐‐
Exactly.
Elon Musk will tell you
he's building the car
for his battery business,
right,
and proof of concept
to demonstrate the technology.
I made an offer.
It's 500K for 20%,
but I personally take Guardian
behind the barn and shoot it.
You don't spend
any time on that.
I've identified
the path to success.
You should listen to me.
I'm absolutely right.
Cuban's 100% wrong.
I'm never wrong.
And so,
at the end of the day,
I'm the only offer
you've got.
It's time
to make a decision.
Riley: Is there another offer
on the table from ‐‐
from either
Lori or Chris?
I was thinking, the only way
this is appealing to me
is if we buy the patent.
I do a lot of manufacturing.
Okay, that's it, guys.
I'm out.
The size of your product alone
makes it difficult.
My offer's pulled back.
Good luck with the other Sharks.
Ohh.
I don't like the disrespect
you've given me.
Kevin, we're ‐‐
we're open to your offer.
We're just trying
to listen ‐‐
We're trying to be respectful
to the other Sharks.
Good luck with you.
Sacca: Look, growing up,
I know there are
three rules to life ‐‐
never go to bed
without flossing,
never text while driving,
and never, ever get involved
in something
this capital intensive,
right?
My great granny told me
those three rules.
Chris, I‐I hear ya.
So, I haven't seen
a clear path to that yet.
I'm tapping the brake.
I'm out.
What I'm feeling here is,
is that there is
some problem with getting them
to put this on every bike.
And so, unfortunately,
because that didn't happen,
I'm gonna go with my gut,
and I'm out.
Okay, I'm gonna make you
an offer, guys,
but there's
a lot of contingencies.
Well...
Okay.
Cuban:
The contingencies are,
you don't get a nickel from me
until there's confirmation
that this is
truly unique, right,
that you are the only player
and it does what you say,
you hit your sales projections
for the next 6 and 12 months,
and the third is,
you hire an internal PR person
to go out there and start
telling people the story.
And I usually hate
hiring PR people,
but I don't think
you're the guys to do it
yourselves, personally.
Okay?
I'm gonna offer you
500K for 15%, all right?
But you're not getting a nickel
till you show me you can sell.
Mark, you got a deal.
Done.
Wow.
Awesome, Mark.
Good going, guys.
Greiner: Congratulations.
I'm so excited.
Thank you.
No butterflies for you.
[ Chuckles ]
Good job.
Man.
Riley: You know, with Mark on
board, we won't have to choose
between Guardian Bikes
and SureStop Technology.
We think we can make
the whole thing successful,
and he's gonna be a
great partner to help
us reach our goals.
I'm actually sad
for you,
because I just saw you turn down
the wrong road into hell.
Bye, Mark. Bye.
Never gonna see him again.
When I talk to my grandkids ‐‐
"I knew Mark Cuban."
"Where's he now, Daddy?"
[ Laughs ]
"He's in hell."
[ Laughter ]